[Music]
foreign
ever wondered what are the biggest movie
monsters that are just from movies and
not TV shows and the ones that are
lifelike as in live action and not
animated or anime so here are the 15 of
the biggest let's get to it
at 15 we have Godzilla from the monster
verse Shin Godzilla destroyer and space
Godzilla so these four are roughly at
the same size the most of us Godzilla
and shin Godzilla differ by just a few
feet whereas destoroya and space
Godzilla are both the same so these four
Kaiju are roughly 120 meters or 400 feet
tall they are all live action Monsters
the first two are CGI based and the
latter two are costumes
at 14 we have Mechagodzilla the
monsterverse one seen in the 2021 GVK
movie he is the largest iteration of the
mechagodzillas it was created by Apex
cybernetics a technology company in the
master verse and with the intention of
defeating and controlling Titans in the
movie Mecca Godzilla was constructed
using Advanced cybernetic technology
powered by the energy source known as
The Hollow Earth power source and also
constructed on the template of King
Ghidorah
13 we have the mega Kaiju this
combination of three other kaijus made
its appearance in the 2018 film Pacific
Rim Uprising unlike regular kaju which
are often by Peter and resemble
creatures not from Earth the mega Kaiju
possesses a unique and more monstrous
design which expresses all three of its
constituent kaijus it is much larger
with multiple limbs powerful jaws and
elongated tails
at number 12 we have the most diverse
Monster Zero in the movie kotm it is
revealed that Master zero agidoro is an
ancient rival of Godzilla and the two
monsters have clashed throughout history
ghidara possesses immense strength
durability and the ability to generate
powerful storms and manipulate weather
conditions throughout the film King
Ghidorah engages in Epic Battles
especially with Godzilla and also with
other tyrants
at number 11 we have slatten appearing
in the 2013 movie Pacific Rim it is
classified as a category 5 Kaiju which
designates it as one of the largest and
most dangerous skaiju to emerge from the
bridge Zlatan has a unique and menacing
appearance it is a reptilian creature
with a massive muscular body covered in
armored plates its head is adorned with
multiple horns and a row of sharp teeth
Zlatan also possesses long whip-like
tails that it can use as deadly weapons
number 10 the sand worm seen in the Dune
movies these are enormous worm-like
creatures from the planet called arakis
a desert Planet also known as dune they
are gigantic in size reaching lengths of
hundreds of meters and having a
distinctive segmented body covered in
tough sand colored skin the most notable
feature is their huge mouth filled with
rows of sharp teeth or sometimes like
frills
and number nine we have soda Serta is a
character that appears in the movie Thor
Ragnarok he has a massive fire demon and
plays a crucial role in the prophesied
event known as Ragnarok at the end of
the movie certain is resurrected by
placing his horn in the Eternal Flame
causing certain to grow to an enormous
size and gain immense power and hence
destroy the realm Eternal along with
Heller
at number eight we have Chronos Kronos
is a powerful and ancient Titan from
Greek mythology and the father of the
Olympian gods in the film series he is
depicted as a colossal and malevolent
entity in Wrath of the Titans Kronos is
imprisoned in the Underworld and seeks
to escape his captivity and exact
revenge on the gods and Humanity Chronos
is portrayed as a massive creature with
burning lava-like skin
number seven hexagot in Star Wars The
Empire Strikes Back the Millennium
Falcon seeks Refuge from the Imperial
Pursuit by flying into an asteroid field
however the crew soon finds out that one
of the asteroids they take shelter in is
in fact a large worm-like creature
called the hexagoth these are enormous
worm-like animals that dwell in the
vacuum of space primarily within
asteroid Fields eating anything that
they can
number six Parallax in Green Lantern the
movie Parallax is portrayed as a
powerful and malevolent entity that
feeds on fear and seeks to consume the
entire universe it was once a guardian
known as Crona who became corrupted by
the power of fear over time it
transformed into a monstrous being
called Parallax a manifestation of fear
itself it is depicted as a massive
swirling cloud of yellow energy with a
menacing and destructive presence
number five the karathan seen in Aquaman
the garathan resides in the hidden sea a
hidden and mysterious part of the ocean
it is depicted as an ancient and wise
being possessing over the top size and
strength its appearance resembles that
of a massive prehistoric sea creature
with rugged scales numerous sharp teeth
and bioluminescent markings as well as
many legs like an underwater crustacean
dragon
number four the adult Glover seen in the
Cloverfield Paradox movie at the very
end of the movie The clever monster was
hundreds of times larger than his baby
form that was attacking New York in the
first Cloverfield movie the baby Monster
was incredibly resilient able to
withstand heavy military Firepower it
also exhibits unique abilities such as
parasitic relationships with smaller
creatures now imagine that as an adult
creature that can reach the clouds not
even nuclear weapons can stop it
number three the Suma verminath in the
movie solo a Star Wars Story the sum of
verminath is a gargantuan predatory
creature that dwells within the
gravitational Maelstrom known as the
mall which has a cluster of black holes
that form a perilous Labyrinth the
creatures depicted as a gigantic
tentacled bees with a gaping moth lined
with sharp teeth like an asteroid size
based jellyfish
number two Unicron seen in the rise of
the bees officially in live action
dismissing the horns of The Last Knight
which we do not count as an appearance
at all Unicron is the ultimate Nemesis
and sibling of Primus in the
Transformers Universe while Primus is
revered as the creator of the universe
Unicron is fitted to devour it consuming
its matter and reality here in the movie
he lived up to it he was seen in all his
glory eating planets creating terracons
and confronting Prime in the end
and number one Airship and the
celestials in the eternals arisham the
prime Celestial was the one who created
the first stars and played a key role in
shaping the universe with the assistance
of other celestials later on he formed
stars planets and life across the cosmos
to ensure the continued progression of
life he must implant Celestial season
various planets leading to the emergence
of new celestials and the death of the
old planets and also the birth of new
stars and life forms later on he was
seen as being impersonal and emotionless
in the movie
so those are the 15 biggest movie
monsters from live action movies anyway
I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam